okay
hopefully i'm live i am starting
a little bit early
because well because i'm ready
dang it what more reason do i need
uh hope people are seeing and hearing me
okay
let me know in the chat
popcorn important stuff
if we're going to do this
so it's probably worth noting
that i'm going to be doing this
the same way that i did
uh the stream
for um
live watching
like when i did howard the duck and
things like that which is that
i'm going to be watching this and
reacting to it but you are not going to
see the thing itself here because i will
get copyright claimed for that
so if you want to know what i'm reacting
to you're gonna have to be watching
the oscars yourself otherwise you're
gonna have no context
for what the heck it is i'm talking
about
right now i'm watching the pre-show
so
liz told me about this that that that
they actually
did the performances of the best
song in the pre-show
rather than and so i've now missed them
all except this one that they're about
to do
so i'm a little annoyed at that
i mean like it it makes
a certain degree of sense it's always
kind of been
one of the things that it's very clear
the oscars has not always known how to
balance in terms of when to insert these
things how to have it go smoothly
but we've got a song
from judas and the black messiah which i
wanted to watch
but what i failed to realize
at the time was that i i knew it debuted
on hbo max
at the same time that it was in theaters
what i didn't realize is it only stays
on hbo max for the first
month and then it goes off that and it's
just in theaters until like
the normal six month window so i missed
my chance to see on an hbo max i'm
actually really annoyed about that
not hbo max's fault i didn't pay
attention
can't you reenact the show for us
no no i cannot
i can't and i won't ah
hey remember uh this doctor who
jody okay all right yep yeah a bunch of
duck puns cause i mentioned howard the
duck
yeah i get it
now the question is
how much of this do i pour all right
well apparently i pour this much
i am digging this song it's it's got a
good groove to it
i'm also going to be texting liz
intermittently because she's watching as
well
and if she has any particularly uh fun
insights
you guys might hear them two i i say
guys i mean that in a gender neutral
term i'm still trying to get out of the
habit of that
okay cool
shame no one will streak again on the
oscars
you say that it'll happen at some point
what am i drinking water
like always
it's uh it's pink moscato flavored water
but it's water
and yes i am drinking it from a beer
stein
because i love this thing
but i hate beer so i will never drink
beer from it
oh thank you caroline yeah she seems to
be having fun she's
unlike me she is she is doing work
while watching this whereas i'm
hanging with you folks
i suppose is kind of work i mean i'm
streaming this on my channel
this is my job yeah
i guess i guess i could claim i'm doing
work
oh god hold on my hair is really bugging
me here
oh that's better the way it was sweeping
across the front of my head i was like
ah
i was not i was not feeling that look
at all you need a silly straw
i need no such thing i am silly enough
on my own
i am job
excuse me i am job sorry the position
has been filled
um oscar the groud should host and the
trophy should be modeled after him
funny the um the oscar betting pool
that was part of the oscar party that i
used to go to you know before the world
ended
um they had a trophy and whoever won
the oscar pool that year you went by
guessing the most
um winners
you know you get your your name put on
the trophies like the stanley cup
and the upper part of the trophy was a
was oscar the grouch spray painted gold
like a like a plastic figurine of them
so my name's on there
hope body has some cabernet sauvignon
water oh
lovely flavor
so liz is is also voicing her support
for the song from judas and the black
messiah
okay so this is the uh the pre-show
stuff
wrapping up
yep yep yep all right so
let's
see about getting to the oscars itself
the oscars are rigged anyway um
they're not they're very predictable
though if you have any sense of pattern
recognition
i mean this is the thing you need to
realize i've always done well in the
oscar pool
despite most years not watching more
than one or two
of the movies nominated for a lot of
awards and i still do really well
not because i have inside knowledge or
because they're rigged
they're just predictable
because the way voting works it it it
actually
it's not supposed to happen but it does
that the way the voting
system is set up that middle of the road
stuff especially for best picture
ends up winning as opposed to um
things with stronger artistic vision so
have you ever lost a bet before not in
any significant way i mean i've lost in
pools like that but like i don't bet i
don't
make like i bet you that no
i'll participate in like things like
oscar pools
for fun but no i don't really gamble
a spoonful of bees says hello just
wanted to say that your videos have been
such a blessing these past few years
you're my comfort youtube channel and i
find listening to your thoughts and
opinions very calming oh thank you
thank you so much
all right
death
i might have to mute this you know
between
stuff actually interesting going on
because
right now i've got advertisements right
in my ear and it's
i get my second jab this week pray i
don't grow tentacles best of luck to
your home body
um if you do grow tentacles um
there i have um i have it on good
authority there are sites where you
could make a lot of money
just saying
ads are most of the reason i canceled
cable tv
not watching the majority of it it was
the reason i
didn't bother with cable tv
but yeah as part of it
excuse me especially like
network tv i get it abc nbc
cbs etc but the minute it's a cable even
basic cable like i'm
paying for this i'm paying for the
privilege to be advertised at
what ugh garbage
sorry i'm late you're not really i mean
the show hasn't really started i came
out a little earlier than i had
originally planned
so liz's big prediction is that they are
going to
give bozeman the best actor basically
um as a
we're not going to get a chance to give
it to you later and she's also
predicting that when they do the
memoriam segment
his image will be the last one shown
that's a decent bat
okay
watching rescuers down under a set of
the oscars
that's solid that's a good movie it's a
really underappreciated movie
okay the 93rd
oscars that is oh
wow that is some shoulders on that dress
wow okay
so we're just gonna throw up all the
celebrities who i really hope
got their second shot two weeks ago or
more
i really hope so
oh marley matlin regina king
uh-huh
i knew i knew liz was gonna send me this
regina king starting us off yeah
like i was like regina king but
the watchmen series new new appreciation
all right
anthony hopkins won the bafta so there's
a possibility he could upset here too
maybe the baptists aren't really
reflective of the oscars though the
voting pool is
very very different okay oh i see how
they're doing this
intimate setting small clusters
okay i still hope they all got
vaccinated already
oh regina oh
don't fall
yeah it's been quite a year you you
think
you think maybe
okay respect to regina king
yeah no absolute respect as a
as a black woman standing on a stage on
a massive platform yeah yeah
bring it up talk about this nonsense do
it
do it
do they change their mind for zoom uh
for
nominees who are in other countries i
have no idea
i'm doing this very much on a whim i've
not been following like what their plans
were
they cast you in a gender swap version
of hamilton would you do it
um now again only is king george
because like the other parts are not
supposed to be white people
they're just not like that's actually
kind of integral to the way the thing is
presented
okay so she's address
oh good i do
i appreciate that they are taking the
time to
recognize that you know they're not
wearing masks
but they've all been tested and they've
been vaccinated and all this other stuff
good
good good
so liz said god she would be so good at
ordering you around
referring to regina king um i will not
argue
ah i have no idea what's going on but
i'm enjoying
it okay
original screenplay see i can't even
remember the nominees
judas and the black messiah
lead actress is the one i cannot call
this year again i can't remember the
i'll i'll tell you what
i am expecting francis mcdormand to win
but i do not want her to because so far
as i could tell
it's the same role she already got an
oscar for in three billboards
what are your thoughts on the disney
movie holes i have not seen it
so i have none
my biggest gripe with hamilton is that
it didn't explain what they hope to do
by
throwing tea into the sea it's not how
you make a cup of tea
ah dang brits
don't appreciate a symbolic gesture when
it comes to destroying tea
promising young woman which i still
haven't seen i do want to see
that one
so the huh so sound of metal which i
know
nothing about at all
it's interesting to me that they're
having
the presenter just explain who these
people are
do they not have a screen to show clips
from
at all like i understand they're in a
smaller space but
really because normally we'd be getting
that right now huh
mank was not this picture i've seen this
year oh no
definitely not manc
random comic fact about the black suit
the superman wears in zack snyder
justice league
he's in the comic said had a lot of
silver and superman had a mullet yes
and he also carried guns
all right so promising young woman just
took the oscar for best original
screenplay
which again
haven't seen i've heard very much things
about the ending
i like the the sparkles on her sleeve
did you hear the controversy surrounding
broadway producer scott rudin i did
i have no particular comments on it at
this time
i probably won't later either i'm not
shocked
it's another high-powered man in
entertainment
huge shock
i think it's pretty yeah i
it's uh see ben you you understand her
she doesn't she doesn't show emotion
um the i'm a little iffy on the frills
around the collar in the in the skirt
part of the dress that
it looks great and on the arms i think
is good i am a little iffy about the
frills on the collar though
the color blending is nice though and i
do i like
i like the shine on it i like the
sparkle well i haven't distinct feeling
since i haven't seen most of these
movies this is
largely going to be a um
fashion commentary which i have no
business doing
as i sit here in a hoodie and a bleeding
heart t-shirt
good gob also the writer of killing eve
season two i haven't seen killing eve
it's actually a show that i don't know
anything about other than the context of
people asking me if i've seen it
no one has ever tried to tell me what
it's actually about
and i actually feel the same about its
marketing it's all about
killing eve have you been killing evie
yet don't you want to know what
everyone's saying about killing eve i'm
like i don't even know what it's
supposed to be about
so no not really that doesn't mean it's
not good it just means
like i don't i don't know if i'd like it
because i literally know nothing other
than people say
that they people should be watching it
all right now into best adapted
chloe zhao for nomad land
i mean i've heard good things about
nomad lamb but i have no interest in
seeing that movie at all
i've always had the opinion that the
oscars are bunk i'm just here to see
you and talk with chat hey that's valid
like i don't put a lot of weight in it
i do i do think they hold
power so like i did legitimately get
ticked off
when green book won and i was
legitimately
relieved and thrilled when the shape of
water won
because i do think the oscars have
importance even though i'm
culturally even though i myself don't
put a lot of stock in them
have you ever played truth or dare i not
for
[Music]
24 years or so
the father yeah i know nothing about
other than anthony hopkins is in it
that's all i've got
i only know killing you from a joke you
know what you what your shiro ship says
about you video
yep
i have an annual bet with my friend saba
for the main film awards
see the oscar pool that i do we we do
all the awards even the technical ones
all right who we got
oh brat subsequent movie film so i guess
they are
they are zooming in some of these folks
i didn't see the second borad either
yeah i'm not shocked by that
all right so they've got these people
seated like
all over the place very weird
just out of curiosity are you and your
friends still doing the ghoul pool the
ghoul pool is still going on i haven't
done that the last few years i just
honestly haven't been motivated but it
is still a thing that exists
what you eating i'm eating popcorn what
else would i eat for the oscars
see it's a good thing that um
this is early on because um
if if i had gotten further into this i
might be foolishly trying to
um take the piss out of this guy's
accent which would be awful
actually i'd like to think even drunk i
wouldn't do that but i'd be nervous
oh the angie
angie pooh pew i never know how to
pronounce that last name but you get a
heart
thank you so much my first stream just
wanted to buy you a coffee oh
thank you very much was onward or soul
nominated
both actually um
if seoul wins i'll be okay with that i
would much rather that wolf walkers win
but i'm okay with soul winning console
was very good onward
god no good grief
don't buy her tea she'll throw it in the
ocean look
just because unlike you with your
uppity british blood right now just
because unlike you i understand the
value of throwing tea in the ocean
doesn't mean i'm gonna
do it for starters vermont's a
landlocked state
so
did you hear see a worse director at the
razzies i
i looked at the razzie winners
briefly earlier today i think
yeah music was on there a lot and no i'm
not i'm not
shocked by that
is onward the new cars no because uh
it'll never get a sequel
all right where's uh where's a mute
because i do not i do not care about
hearing the ads
i was glad shawn the sheep got nominated
as someone i know and really care about
was one of the animators well the
aardman movies have a tendency to get
nominated
they don't win often but they get
nominated pretty consistently
soul was good but i didn't think it was
that good like i wouldn't even put in my
top 10 pixars it would probably make my
top 10 pixars but that's also
taking into account i'm nowhere near as
in love with pixar as
like the entire rest of my generation
for starters i don't think the first toy
story is very good
and watch you now all abandon me and
flee and and um subscribe and
stop supporting me on patreon because of
that one
champ is more of a coffee type monster
this is this is true
he needs his morning buzz
[Laughter]
[Music]
for folks who don't know champ is the uh
is the lake champlain
monster it's our attempt to have our own
loch ness
i haven't seen soul yet it's okay
carowind it's good though i'd recommend
it
something i love doing is taking
abilities characteristics of one
character and giving them to different
characters in a different world
think of the possibilities any scenarios
um not off the top of my head
i mean it's not that's not an exercise
i'm used to engaging in
with so first choice is a great allegory
for a child getting a new sibling
well then maybe the reason i don't i
never connected with it very well is
because i'm an only child
i mean makes about as much sense as
anything else
this stream got a like for the pixar
opinion oh thank you
but what about the founding fathers plan
for milk where were they going to get
enough
milk for all the tea they were throwing
in the seed they didn't think it through
well speaking personally
i don't put milk in my tea
or sugar or a lemon
or honey i just you know
drink my tea
crazy i know
i'm a chai person i i like chai but i'm
really
really picky about chai
wally's my favorite pixar film
wall-e is one-third of a masterpiece
there you go
unpopular opinion woody's a jerk and
that first movie especially oh yeah
yeah he is you don't think wicked could
work as a movie
or all dogs go to heaven could work as a
broadway musical i'm starting to see a
pattern here yeah
the pattern is oftentimes these things
are well tailored to the medium they're
originally put into
and you gain nothing by moving them to
another medium that is similar enough
that all you can do is hope to recreate
it from the original
i see very little artistic value in
doing that
ever
okay your nation is doomed i mean it was
anyway
so so is ours but that's just
the general state of the world look
if you are too cowardly
to take tea as it comes i that's on you
laura dern what are you wearing
what i
okay whoa i
wait a minute i
i don't it's like she's she's just
wearing
it's like it's half steve jobs and half
bjork what is this
outfit oh my god
okay
all right international i definitely am
not going to know these
sorry i'm texting liz she she is sharing
my sentiments with
laura dern's outfit oh well just watch
mad
madsmickles and get drunk i can get
behind that
i was i've been writing a story and was
wondering if i could get your opinion i
could give you the cliff notes
um i mean if you want to send me the
cliff notes i can give you ideas on
concepts i
really don't have time to read other
people's stuff right now as far as
getting into the nuts and bolts of it
if you had to choose would you rather
have a wicked movie or all dogs go to
heaven the broadway musical if one had
to exist
i would rather have the all dogs go to
heaven broadway musical
just because i think it would be more
interesting to see what they do to adapt
it
strange usually last year supporting
actress winter present supporting actor
yeah i mean this whole year is going to
be weird
okay
i'm gonna have no opinion on these wins
at all
so liz said liz sent me this when um
when mads megelson was dancing around
drinking oh
movie about danes drinking is such a
stretch she's allowed to say that
because her heritage is danish
would you ever feel comfortable in the
hospital on doctor who's new earth
inhabited by cat people
i mean only if i didn't know what i know
as a viewer about what went
on there assuming i did not have the
knowledge of a
viewer yeah maybe
the drinking danes whoo
was jubilee to dalek a somewhat unique
adaptation
has any work just adapted one subplot
from another piece before
um
not exactly it's not uncommon when
something gets adapted to a medium that
is
that has to compress the storytelling
like from a novel to film
or in the case of jubilee from audio to
tv episode it's not uncommon for
subplots to be dropped
i can't think of another instance where
a single subplot
basically became the entire thing though
usually you usually you have an
agreed-upon central plot that
gets carried over and then a bunch of
subplots get dropped so it might be
unique in that way
wow you really don't think wiki could
work as a movie no
i just think it's absolutely freaking
pointless to ever do wicked as a movie
because it's a spectacle show the point
is to see that level of
production and effects on a stage to do
it as a film
it is not unique it it it just looks
like a million other films
it's not that it would be bad it's not
that it wouldn't work
it's that it would serve absolutely no
purpose
at all
wait danes have a stereotypical trait of
drinking i don't know if they do but
again
liz is danish so
i i'm taking her word on her life
experience
max michaelson worked with the same
director on the hunt which was a really
powerful film i've heard really good
things about the hunt
i still haven't seen it
i don't remember that song miss wicked
wolf
i love the beer advert mads was in
hannibal lecter selling the
me alcohol is everything i ever wanted
that would terrify me
so he's still going through his thank
yous
number one reason i don't think we need
a wicked movie is because we don't need
a cat's movie either i actually think
the
um the more um
cogent comparison would be the phantom
of the opera movie
it's just it brings nothing that the
stage play didn't already do and a lot
of stuff
that it did worse than it ever was on
stage
one reason i might be in favor of a
wicked movie is because this would make
it much more economically
accessible compared to the broadway
production
i mean
that's about the one argument that i see
that i don't
really have a counter to um and i see
that brought up sometimes especially if
i am
complaining about how an adaptation
doesn't adapt and just does the exact
same story again which ticks me off
on um on principle
however there is an argument to be made
about
bringing it to an audience who otherwise
would not get to experience it now
it's still not bringing the same
experience
it's not even bringing the experience of
like filming the
stage play but it is
it is bringing more of an experience
than you could have
just by um
just by listening to the soundtrack
and i'm not going to say there's no
validity to that
it's just that it's not part of my own
personal calculations when i'm assessing
a piece of adaptation as an artistic
work in and of itself
i'm not saying that's an invalid thing
or that there isn't value in that
it's just not part of my own calculus
when i assess these things but that's me
have you been to your senior prom no not
yet but i hope to go one day
oh okay supporting actors
lakeith stanfield i'll i'm i'll be good
with him winning
because he's i i haven't seen jesus in
black messiah but he is good
they really are not using
very many clips at all
and daniel kaluuya is awesome
unfortunately
because they're both nominated for the
same film that is probably going to
split the vote
ah
leslie i'm junior i don't know anything
about one night in miami
is that a tardis sign yes yes it was
all right i don't know this actor and i
also don't know sound of metal
brian l thank you very much i'd be your
companion
aww thank you very much
nathaniel ryan and paul's high school
reunion won
well like well they didn't go to my high
school first of all
and they're both uh older than me ryan's
only a year older than me paul's a
couple of years older than me so we
wouldn't have been in the same grade
anyway
trial of chicago seven i i was going to
watch that
friday night but i had a migraine
so that didn't happen
i have three must-haves for a wicked
movie adina kristen and it's animated
i mean if you're gonna do anime then
there would be truly no reason that you
couldn't use them because the reason
they're tricky to have live action is
because their visible age
ooh
okay i didn't think daniel kaluuya was
going to be able to win because i fit i
figured him and lee keith would split
that vote
oh that's nice
now you know what i want it won't happen
i want
him to give a speech reminiscent of his
breakdown on
on uh black mirror but
let's let the man have his moment
oh god his mother and his sister are so
proud of him
oh
what happened with black mirror you need
to see the episode 10 million merits to
know what i was talking about
barclay doing the doctor yeah i keep
forgetting he was i wish he could have
been in a better doctor who episode that
is a shame
the hunt disturbed me for a very
personal reason in that the young girl
the main plot centers around look
exactly like my niece ah
yeah okay that would do it
which episode was in he was in um
the the dead planet or the planet of the
dead
whatever it was the the um
the special the tenant excuse me special
with later chris
lady christina de souza where they were
stuck in the desert and there were the
flying metal eating stingray things
and the flies and in jumpsuits
is there any way to watch the oscars in
the uk i don't
know
i mean i like michelle ryan but that's
about it yeah there's a lot to recommend
that episode
hahaha
more acceptance speeches need to
culminate
in the awardee basically thanking his
parents for having sex
i need that in more
acceptance speeches in my life
oh
oh my goodness
have you seen miraculous ladybug nope
i'm saying this now as much as i want
glenn to finally get an oscar if she
wins this year for this performance i'm
gonna throw something
yeah nothing i saw about that film
looked very good at all
um and i love
glenn close don't get me wrong but
uh yeah
oh it's okay so they're now they're
previewing west side story
which is another thing i don't need in
my life
uh yeah so this is like a this is a
trailer this isn't like a clip or
something
steven spielberg film trying to remember
i feel like spielberg must have directed
a musical at some point hasn't he
but i also can't think of one maybe he
hasn't
i don't know
mario
okay so
yeah that looks like west side story
i've seen the one with natalie wood yep
i have
okay let me
mute this ah
i'm assuming that ansel elgort hasn't
been removed from it
did i miss something
uh now i'm trying to remember i feel
like there was
something that i knew about ansel elgort
and now i can't remember
uh
all right
accusations about stuff back in 2014
yeah no i guess he wasn't um
dang popcorn ham
ah i didn't know that but i'd forgotten
about it
because he's not an actor that i had a
lot of investment in so it didn't stick
in my head
but yeah
the music is so good i mean it's just
oh jekyll and hyde i don't know if the
music in that is any good because
i've i saw i saw the version with
hasselhoff and i don't think that's a
good
measure for whether or not it's any good
sorry texting
and that's still gonna happen
[ __ ] how did i hear that right no i
try i think i said hasselhoff
remember when david hasselhoff was nick
fury i remember that it happened
never watched it and we're back don
cheadle
one of the coolest suckers in the room
let's go
i am mesmerized by his bow tie
makeup and hair
don't know that movie at all
yeah i don't really care about that
movie winning anything
i mean yeah it always seems odd to me
how often
something wins and
same for mink it's always how often
things get nominated or when that are
just
recreating old style
hair and makeup i'm like you're
you're working off of old photographs
i just it frustrates me because like i
don't see that much creativity in there
i mean it's fun my rainy and general
winning stuff i'm like that's fine
but i stand by my general thing like
you're recreating hairstyles
from a period that you have photographs
for
i just i i would rather make up and hair
go to something more
creative than that
yeah ms wicked wolf that's the second
time you said that i'm not repeating it
it's it's you're alleging things that i
i'm not gonna repeat on stream
black panther was a great example that
yeah black panther
is a excellent example of creating
something
that is influenced by things but isn't
just
copying and like i feel the same about
costume design
when it's a historical
film that we have a lot of reference for
like i just don't i mean
it's not unimpressive but like i'm much
more impressed by someone who had to
create something as opposed to
someone who had to recreate something
you know
all right i think it's for viola's
transformation
i mean she still looked like viola davis
though i wouldn't have called that
makeup job a transformation
that's let's say it was bad makeup it
wasn't but you know
most academy voters are too nostalgic
for those haircuts i get
i guess i mean i it's more an issue of
most academy voters turn their nose up
app
um at genre fiction which is where you
get the more creative
use of hair and makeup
oh costume design
this is real this presentation style is
really weird to me
that they are having the presenter talk
about these things
rather than just show us clips that
illustrate the things that like
show off the costumes show off the hair
and makeup
i think part of what's rubbing me the
wrong way about it
is hearing them talk about it makes the
whole thing
seem more nakedly self-aggrandizing than
it already is
because when you show the clips it's
like showing to the audience who may not
have seen the movie
this is what we're talking about this is
the work we are honoring
where it's just having them stand just
having the presenters stand there and go
oh and you did this wonderful amazing
stuff i'm like
show don't tell i mean
come on
this will be my rainy again maybe
yeah not a shock hair and makeup and
costume
can often go hand in hand
your drag name is your grandmother's
first name and the last suite you ate
alfredo werthers
maybe the academy couldn't afford the
rights to show the clips
i mean given how bad the uh
ratings have been of late
and how they're probably not expecting a
huge
turnout over the ratings for this year i
wouldn't be surprised if they didn't
budget for that
all right let me mute these ads
ah
texting liz some more
you know what i am kind of glad um
that i am just live streaming this
because it means i won't have to do a
summation video
later like yeah you want to know what i
thought just just watch the
let's watch the thing
olivia coleman just got signed to secret
invasion days ago really i missed that
ooh i still really wanted her to be the
doctor
did you review invincible or manc i
can't find them anywhere um i didn't
review mank but i used it as a leaping
off point for
my video on um
hollywood's historical revisionism
um and no i haven't seen invincible at
all
do you think six could work as a movie
no his entire premise
and presentation relies on the inherent
suspension of disbelief
that comes with a theater production and
i think
it no it would not translate to film
did you ever watch season two of
harlequin yes i've seen it
i've shot a review of it i need to edit
it
but you know i'm trying to get the uh
the book edited right now so
did you watch netflix space film
stowaway i did not
she's had the requisite guest appearance
already
oh geez just spat out a bit of popcorn
i'm so sorry
have you heard of pip in the musical
heard of it yes seeing it now
vera next week your plate's full with
this one yeah i i did get um
a video edited to put up on the break
room
i don't know maybe monday or tuesday but
yeah that that stuff's all back burner
even the stuff i've already shot
what if there was a live concert film of
six then it would suffer from the
problem of all
live concert films which is you're going
to sit there going boy i bet this would
be a lot better live than seeing a
recording of it
humanitarian award very odd to me
that they have brian cranston presenting
the humanitarian award
not that he isn't a humanitarian but you
know he's
he's most famous for playing an absolute
bastard
are you drunk yet i am not as think as
you drunk i am
you people are really into trying to get
me to say that might work
isn't it what if that movie starts as
actors in a play like jesus christ
superstar
joseph and the amazing technicolor
dreamcoat see i would argue neither of
those really worked as films
either so you're not selling me on this
one of my fan castings for doctor is
tania miller
bit nervous to bring this up because she
was in
hellbent oh okay her took me a second i
was like i know that name and i don't
know why
she could work i i still say like please
just
please just let joe martin be the doctor
please like properly in a series
have you seen the sci-fi series pandora
no i have not
oh tracy dale hello thank you tracy
you get a heart glad you're live
streaming this tonight wasn't going to
watch this year but this seemed like a
fun way to follow hi to you and liz
hi to you too and hi from liz who's
texting me
[Laughter]
liz's idea for future oscars is uh to
have regina king and daniel kaluuya host
next year
and they hand out muppets
oh and that here there it is the all
caps of her saying that
she would have nominated delroy lindo i
would have to
the fact that delroy lindo did not get
nominated for defy bloods
is a goddamn crime
he was so
good he was so good
playing a part that was so
hard for anyone to do
i don't know if you notice i
accidentally crushed that
bit of popcorn and now fell on the floor
but oh
god dang
what's your favorite andrew lloyd webber
musical um
it's probably phantom that's a bit of a
generic answer i'm sure but
it's a good show
humanitarian award okay
i this brilliant idea for a musical
based on the fly didn't they do an
opera based on the fly i'm pretty sure
that was the thing
what's your favorite steven sondheim
musical probably sweeney todd
is it okay for the doctor to wield a bfg
if they never shoot a person with it
in a specific story sure
like as a matter of course like to just
always have it and never shoot it no
no
i feel bad because i have no idea who
this is because i wasn't paying
attention
and it's it's a humanitarian award so
like i should
but i didn't
do you have a movie soundtrack even if
you didn't love the film as much
tron legacy that soundtrack is
amazing and the film is
[Music]
love a bit of daft punk yeah i know i
know it
it hit jesse hard when they broke up and
i was like it's a couple of robots who
won't be making music
look i like some of their stuff but
peter davidson's fifth doctor did an
earth shock and he fired it too multiple
times into a cyberman's chest
i mean he also shot omega
the fifth doctor was a violent bastard
two redeeming things about tron legacy
the score in michael sheen yeah michael
sheen
he like he betters everything
this is still going on about delroy
lindo not getting a nomination for the
five bloods
i love how upset she is about that
righteous fury
another thing i'm just saying
they don't have a playoff this year
there's no band to like start to play to
get them to wrap it up
so the speeches are running longer
phantom of the opera sweeney todd
probably sweeney todd just because
sweeney todd's part's actually in my
singing range so you know
there's the there's the narcissism
factor
oh
is he supposed to be subtitled
oh okay
that's intentional they think people
want to hear longer speeches i'm not
sure
where they pulled that information from
it was tyler perry you got the
humanitarian award so medea has an oscar
and got close doesn't the humanitarian
award isn't really an oscar in the same
way though
and that's fine he does a lot of work
giving back to the community that's fine
sweeney todd or hamilton i don't know i
am not that invested
in comparing things i don't
like it enough give it a rest for
tonight
please
another round okay so that's the movie
that already won
best foreign language
menari which i know nothing about
chloe xiao which again
i have no interest in nomad lamb but you
know
i i i'm not gonna complain if a woman
wins best director
promising young woman still haven't seen
it very
sound like my nine-year-old has to play
would you rather with me just know
i just like i i don't mean to snap but i
i do hit a point where like it
it was fun for a bit but like give me a
break
oh fincher no god
no
ah
okay
i think ms wikiboo was trying to compile
your psychological profile should i just
hand her the notes i've already made i
mean if you if you guys want to
share notes you might as well um
i think i think the thing is like
part of my reservation to answering
those kinds of questions especially
a lot of them is
i my answers are going to change with my
mood
so i always have something in the back
of my head is like is is this person
asking me so they can hold it
over me later and then at some later
date say hey you said you like this
better than this
when my mood's in a different place and
i give a different answer and i'm like
i don't keep track of what i said
previously my
uh my mood shift my feeling shift
all right hang on a second um
all right thank you very much um
carowind for bringing that comment to my
attention sorry eric that i missed it
when it passed by
i saw your video about representation
this morning
loved it and wanted to say thank you it
really touched me
gaze cis white man i send my love
for all the hate thrown your way for
existing
thank you eric thank you very much
and i'm i'm glad that it connected with
you
thank you
i love that frances mcdormand still has
her mask on like they made a point of
saying
everybody's vaccinated everybody's
everything and she's still sitting there
with a
mask on
now tell us your mother's maiden name in
the last four digits of your
social security number
[Laughter]
wait the doing director already the the
order is all over the shop
i mean they always say best picture for
last that's a given
but
why are they playing live and let die
what what was that
that was weird
eternals is now directed by an oscar
winner yep fair point
i showed my boyfriend ghostbusters for
the first time today
i loved his reaction to dana um
save some bone structure for someone
else why don't you
uh sigourney weaver oh
oh dang man
um
having trouble keeping up now my husband
made me meet love with my 12 year old
set of guinea pig in my lap
mike uh so i haven't talked about this
up to this point but my um my kid's
hamster
passed away last week and
uh she decided to go a different
direction
with the replacement so now
now she has rats
so
excuse me if someone asks
you if you're a god you say yes
i love that everyone's reaction is oh no
i love
rats rats are amazing they are wonderful
day
yes yes angie they are smart and they
are affectionate they are
sweethearts they are wonderful
i've had pet rats before
at the risk of this being in poor taste
yeah why not it's better to try
including representation
we're seeing it going wrong or not
include until included until you're more
confident
you'll get it right
so that's one of those questions where
i do not accept that as a binary
i think the only time that you are
including representation and quote
unquote
risking getting it wrong is when you're
not
consulting with that group
and you cannot count on the act if it's
a
film or tv you cannot count on the actor
that you've hired
speak up if there are things problematic
about it because
if they're not a big name they're not
going to speak up
they're just going to do the work they
were hired for because they need the
work
so you know all you have to do
is get somebody in the writer's room get
somebody's
i ideally several somebody's eyes on
the script and
so i don't accept the binary of well you
either do it and maybe it sucks or you
don't do it at all
no you do it and if you're afraid it
sucks have
people from the group you're trying to
represent read the script
before you shoot the damn thing
sensitivity readers they're not
expensive and they're not hard to find
i remember you saying on twitch you had
a pet rat named nicodemus growing up it
wasn't when i was growing up it was when
i lived in new york so i was um
i was i was in my 20s
hardly growing up
a wild rat ran across the stage during
one of our theater productions once
ah
i feel the specter of failure you're
looming regardless maybe it's just me
but
that's part of being a creative
that's part of pouring your heart soul
into a piece of creative work
and putting it out there at all you're
going to dread
that it's all kinds of wrong that
it sucks and your characters are shallow
and
your twists are predictable and like
that's that's
just that's just the process
my friend
excuse me oh
i'm starting to get buffering on my
stream of the
ceremony which is annoying
i know nothing of make but every time i
say the movie's name we keep thinking it
must be a 70s cop drum
it would have been more interesting if
it was
oh for god's sake
considering what has been happening of
late the fact that we've had two asian
best
director winners in a row seems right
yeah yeah that is nice
sound of metal
okay fun fact shannon doherty who voiced
teresa mrs brisby's eldest daughter also
played heather
duke and heather's okay
perhaps you've not updated your real
player software i
mean that's possible it's also possible
that my computer is an ancient piece of
garbage
how does the grinch get ready to go out
why do i have the feeling like that's
the setup to a joke that i'm gonna groan
at
did you hear that mean girls is not
reopening on broadway i did not
you you really should have gathered by
now i don't really
pay attention to what's going on on
broadway like
at all
i mean i cared a bit more when i
actually lived in new york
and could theoretically go and see these
things
but i no longer do and i ain't
making the trip to go do it so
i don't really care
oh man i feel bad for him he's like that
was a perfectly valid question
and that was
that was unexpectedly telling that he
just asked the audience
how many of you got your start on a
short film
and freaking nobody
nobody responded to that yeah
all these sons yeah
uh it's very telling that the people in
at the oscars are people who like have
worked they got they got towards the top
quick
i filmed with sound in it style just one
best sound
yeah huge shock
when did you see wicked on broadway
maybe i can guess who was playing
alphabet and
glinda at the time i don't remember what
year it was and even if you did
accurately guess
i wouldn't be able to verify anyway i
don't remember who was playing them
my paint yes i'm i i've take i
took chipping nail polish off a couple
of nails so i i am repainting now
as the blue man group in new york when
they were off broadway
that was one trippy show i saw blue man
group in boston
good stuff
you know
i am uh
i am glad that people are taking
advantage
of the platform
this year usually it's a lot more
sporadic
than this it's been pretty consistent
with basically anybody american
especially american and black
getting up there and saying flat out
yeah this is screwed up
and keeps happening
i'm sorry i didn't mean to laugh but
it's a little weird that
the white guy that also
gets up to the mic and goes i want to
thank netflix
like after this other guy talked about
police killing
black people and this other guy
giving him a much more traditional
acceptance thank you speech it's odd
uh okay there we go
getting that going
ms wicked wolf i really don't know what
to do with these questions about if they
cast you in bleb would you do it like
the answer unless i feel like i am
fundamentally wrong for a specific part
the answer is always going to be yes
because i'm
i'm a failed actor yeah i would say yes
to the work
like i don't know what to do with those
questions when you ask them
like i don't i don't feel like i have
anything interesting to say about it
is there anywhere to stream the awards
i'm streaming them on youtube
tv which i am on free trial of
and i will be canceling as soon as this
is over
saw the blue man group in vegas blue man
groups is uh
is a really unique piece of work they
are good stuff
ah
did you watch wolf walkers and if so do
you think they'll win i did and i don't
they should seoul will probably win and
i don't
uh i won't hate it if soul wins
it's just i'm very sick of pixar winning
and like
for all the years that they've won when
they should not have i
kind of want them to not win for a while
but you know that's that's just me i'm
stupid and bitter
uh youtube tv 64.99 a month what yeah i
mean it's
it's basically a cable package is what
it is
sub to youtube tv so we don't have to
your sacrifice is noted
i mean like i said i i'm canceling as
soon as this is over
so i'm just doing it on the free trial
basis
you're not stupid and bitter yeah sure i
am
almost 40 years old if i if i
thought i was smart then i wouldn't have
been paying attention if i wasn't bitter
then i really wouldn't have been paying
attention
if they cast you as me in a biopic about
me would you say
yes i i'm not sure i could capture your
british stoicness ben
i i'm not sure that i could manage that
they've rebundled bundling i mean yeah
this this is all just
this is people paying attention
called this years ago too that
streaming services would eventually just
try and recreate the cable model
and they have
uh
i think you're smart it's because i
fooled you
as long as you're polite about it i
sometimes i'm sometimes polite
that smiled that ass though
i'm sorry uh i couldn't stop myself
animated short okay
reese what are you doing
do you like twix i haven't had twix a
long time but yeah
i like twix well enough sophia
how did you go about portraying ben
warburton
lots of nodding and yelling about t yeah
i mean that there isn't anything else to
you i think i think i got it
yeah cartoon uh saloon and like our
animation studios they keep getting
shafted
yeah yeah regularly
what you lacking smarts you make up for
in wisdom
i'll take it
reese stop going off script
you're not good at it
reese oh my god
okay i mean i didn't i didn't see any of
the animated shorts so okay
hey sometimes i yell about doctor who
i'm a complex character
damn it proceeds to cry into tea
[Music]
oh they're still up for a lightsaber
duel i mean my lightsaber's upstairs
and i'm um
hydrated so
if if you ever get cast anything they
better make use of your evil laugh
here's the thing like
so i can deliberately try and do evil
laughs but i
i've also i also have this channel to
thank for pointing out that some people
apparently think my normal laugh is
actually fairly evil
i remember when i put up the uh my
reaction video to the first episode of
um god what the heck are they are
the uh the inhumans
that's what it was and i laughed at some
of those parts
and i had multiple comments saying that
i sounded like the joker
and i was just laughing
it's just my laugh
that's not even trying to be evil but
yes i do have my evil laugh repertoire
all right now on to gun violence okay
okay uh
have you ever made a typo before no no
in fact
i've never in my entire life ever
had a typo uh happen
for me that's never happened
i've seen the animated short winner it's
heartbreaking ah
voice acting well funny you mentioned
voice acting
um if you folks aren't already
subscribed to the who chaser
in a couple of weeks
well this time next week
um he will start debuting his doctor who
fan audios doctor who remnants
and the second of those scheduled to go
up
features me doing voice work which
was a lot of fun to do and i hope i get
to do again in the future
the inhumans was unintentionally
hilarious though it oh god when they
when they
took out the clippers like you're in a
city on the moon
and you keep zoo was god it was awful
onward don't you dare win don't you
dare
now they're actually using clips this
this knight is so
inconsistent
your laugh sounds like it comes from a
cruel person
no offense
wasn't that the april fool's day video
uh
year before last joker laughs yeah yeah
a couple years ago
over the moon which i haven't seen
no not that one i do i don't know enough
about it to have a strong opinion
either way
i mean i'm down for sean the sheep
winning anything
it won't but i'd be down for it
soul was good it was very good
uh
oh wolf walkers that one was good that
one was good
yeah that was uh
like i i discovered this studio
after secret kel's got nominated i'm
like i don't know what that is and it
looks really interesting
who got it who got it
yeah okay i knew soul was gonna win
like i'm not shocked that soul won it's
it's fine it's not a travesty it's not
like brave winning good grief
is she
is she wearing a picnic blanket
are you happy that soul won no i'm not
thrilled but i i
i ain't mad at it
brave suck brave was a disappointment
brave had a great setting beautiful
animation and a phenomenal central
character
and used all that to tell a really
really really
boring predictable and yet oddly
disjointed story
one of my favorite moments in any of
your videos was you're excited
oh when you looked up how
scott buck's career was doing how
is he has he still has he still not done
anything
ooh ooh now now i want to check that now
i want to check that
let's see i love brave and that's fine
like you're not wrong for liking it but
i just found very little to
to recommend it but like
you know i'm also a grumpy bugger who
scott buck what have you been doing
[Laughter]
scott buck has vanished off the face of
the entertainment
world since the inhumans oh he hasn't
done anything since 2017.
oh
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh that feels good that feels like
justice
brave launch well but couldn't stick the
landing yeah i think
once the main plot of brave kicked in it
lost
me
uh
i always felt badly for thinking brave
was like lester i wanted to like brave
i like the setting i like that part of
the world i like the kind of
lore that it's dealing in and folklore
and like merida as a character but like
it's just not a very good
movie i don't think
uh
mate you're gonna jinx it scott buck
will be a new show runner for doctor who
ah they won't hire him he's not
he's not uh from the uk
besides
look here's here's the thing
about um
this is the thing about
someone like scott buck not getting work
anymore that
really really is
a testament to how bad his output was
because as a rule of thumb
if you deliver your work on time and on
budget
you'll keep getting employed maybe at a
lower profile if it doesn't do that well
but if you can do those two things which
he did consistently
then you'll get you'll still get hired
and he can't even get working despite
having nailed those two things
lord
how would you fix brave i would have to
think about that when i'm not as
hydrated as i currently am i think you'd
make a great actor
i think so too because i am an egomaniac
uh meredith's voice actress kelly
mcdonald is in the current series of
line of duty here in the uk
okay is that a cop show
name like that i would assume
uh
that had to be on budget it was so cheap
looking oh the inhumans
oh yeah i think that was that had a
budget of
a kettle and two pieces of string
even as a parent i really thought the
queen needed to loosen up her
expectations of merida
yeah that was part of it the the
conflict between
those two was very rote and very
unnuanced
will you do another how to fix episode i
love that video i don't know
because i love that video i'm really
proud of that video
it got no views like at all
so it would have to it would have to be
something
that i'm really passionate about i mean
the closest that i've come to it was
with the watchman video which wasn't a
how would i fix because my ultimate
conclusion is you really shouldn't have
been doing that
uh adapting that straight in the first
place but
if there was another thing that i was
passionate enough about i i
i would do it again but
you know it's hard to get up the
motivation
yay marley matlin or maitland
all right she's awesome either way
oh documentary short subject i was
wondering what this was
they should have given brenda chapman
full control of the story for brave
i i would be really curious to know what
her
original vision of the movie was i'm not
going to go so far as to automatically
say it would have been better but i am
very curious at this point
release the chapman cut
you should dress up like david tennant's
ghost of christmas present from
catherine tate's christmas special
i could see you dancing into a room to
the ghostbusters song
i would need to look up what that even
looked like
vera not until you have more breathing
room in your schedule yes
yes carowind is very very great
moana's superior to brave oh god buy a
by a country mile moana's great
no angie i have not seen the magicians
yet
what was i oh ham
so i was going to look up david tennant
ghost of christmas presents
oh that's like um
that's almost like a prototype crowley
huh i'm sorry crowley
i i say that wrong
see rowan i still haven't seen prince of
egypt
do you stream from the break room i mean
the break room
is the same setup as my
um main setup just from a different
angle
i may have to break oh stretch my legs
and use the bathroom at the next ad
break
i'm not really watching but i thought
i'd ask on the one thing that interests
me did seoul get an oscar yet or not it
did brandon
it it won best animated
i didn't like death's becomes her when
the the one time i tried to watch death
becomes her
i was uh i was honestly too young to
appreciate what it was trying to do
so i didn't finish it and i didn't
really like it but
like again i didn't really get it either
so
i don't really have an opinion on that
one
ah
um
what's death becomes her it's it's a
movie from the 90s it's a very strange
film dark comedy
riley maitland looks amazing
i actually say she might be the best
dressed of this entire evening
god how does she still look that good my
god
do you think onward could work as a tv
show um
not as a narrative the setting could oh
man it'd be a decent enough setting for
a tv show
you need to i mean you probably just go
episodic with it
it really is sporadic and random when
when they are um
when they're using clips
the whole argument people say regarding
danny and
cobra could also be used for prince of
egypt regarding moses
i guess i hadn't really thought about
that
that's that's an octopus
okay
have you been watching debris on nbc
nope
i don't watch network television have
you read the wiki book nope i own it
but no i haven't read it
documentary feature
my octopus teacher
it's an oscar puss
oh my god that was terrible
oh what is wrong with me
considering that i'm not watching the
show just listening here a few of these
comments sound very intriguing
uh about half of us aren't watching yeah
that sounds about right uh
i know you didn't oh yes i did callie
i'm deeply deeply shamed but yes i did
oh
uh
my friend won for my octopus teacher i
went for collective
my money would have been on [ __ ] camp
honestly
um
it was there james bond with a similar
name
homebody you are thinking of octopussy
i haven't seen that one uh would prefer
not to just based off uh
title alone
uh
ah
octopuses james bond dressed as a clown
oh is that that one
i've never known what what one that
image came from
yeah best to avoid octopussy for a
couple of questionable more quips
regarding indian people
i mean like i i hope you avoid
you only die twice for the same reason
because holy crap
i mean there was also bond character
named [ __ ] galore
here's part of what i love about um
[ __ ] galore though
it's um
it's the fact that part of why i
i cannot remember her name now part of
why the actress took the job
was she loved being able to say that
name
in interviews
okay commercial break i need to go
stretch my legs real quick
and avail myself of the facilities
so so i will be back
presently yeah i've got
popcorn in my crotch mmm crotch corn
all right
hmm
hmm
oh
all right
is it uh
is it bad that for the briefest of
seconds
i thought do i need to keep my pants on
for the rest of this and i was like
right i need to climb back into the
chair
so yes probably best to keep wearing
pants
i see people are on bond now as a
as a topic
oh headed to headed to bed well given
the time difference
um have a good night's sleep then
pants are overrated they are
pants suck man skirts are where it's at
do you think the next bond could be a
woman without being a detriment to his
playboy character
character or go to work if she was a
lesbian
um
i don't under like here's the thing
i don't know how to engage with the
question about should
bond be a woman because i don't think it
it could not meaningfully still be
bond you could have a woman be
double 07 but to try and have a woman
personify
bond i just i don't think it works
because the character
the character is
is an embodiment of very specific
masculine elements and those elements
take on different meanings
when played by a woman
i would be okay with seeing someone take
a crack
at a female equivalent to bond as its
own
franchise but i i feel like the idea of
making
james bond a woman not like making a
woman double
seven fine whatever but making a
um making
like gender swapping james bond
specifically just
i don't understand why you would do that
oh visual effects okay
all right i like your slippers thank you
nothing super exciting for uh visual
effects this year
actually
tenet okay i still haven't seen that i
keep waiting for it to show up on
streaming for free and not be a rental
trans male james bond then um
maybe
maybe
yeah maybe
i want to see tenant but i saw some
terrible reviews on it i saw what i
would describe as under enthusiastic
reviews but i mean
that kind of just comes with the
with um christopher nolan
making a movie that doesn't live up to
his best movies you know it's just kind
of what happens
atomic blonde was one hell of a ride i
love the action in atomic blonde the
plot
was it was friggin indecipherable
you should be james bond
uh bond
james bond vodka martini sure is stirred
not shaken because when you shake it
you ruin the freaking martini by shaking
a vodka martini you
flip an idiot i was a bartender that
pisses me off
actress in a supporting role
he's starting to look really old around
the eyes
brad pitt is
considering i can't remember the plot of
atomic bomb i guess you're right yeah
that's kind of my point
like the action scenes are phenomenal
but
where
ah
i couldn't remember where i put my phone
ah
all right i haven't seen any of the well
no i've seen mank
zhu zhung yoon for menari don't know
anything about it but
congrats oh she looks so happy
okay i support this i don't even know
what the movie's about but i support
this
uh
do you watch monk nope never did
out of the blue ever watch horrible
histories it's on youtube
i've heard of it i've never watched it
tired what a little yeah i won't lie
uh
wait something going on asking my
opinion wait what did i miss what's
going on
uh i can't backtrack and figure out what
the heck was going on
all right if you feel the need to catch
me up on something oh here we go
jessica and i are discussing which
disney villains
aren't toxic masculine i was arguing
that frollo technically wasn't
uh
[Music]
he was not an embodiment of traditional
masculine traits but he was using his
position of power which was granted to
him by virtue of being a man
in order to try and coerce a woman into
having sex
with him yes he freaking was
the fact that i did not swear just now
i i deserve another drink
i feel like when you're talking about
something like toxic masculinity
the idea of breaking out a technical
definition
is misplaced
okay this is adorable how how how could
i win
over glenn close oh my god this is
wonder i love this speech oh
do you have a grover plushie um
no my child has a super grover
and glenn close is officially the female
peter o'toole yeah
possibly
i was thinking it was something but
toxic masculinity wasn't it like
claude frollo is
his toxicity which it like he has the
entitlement
he has the entitlement to a woman's body
that would come with toxic masculinity
now it is
filtered through a religious lens
and so you can add in
um elements of religious trauma and a
cycle of um religious harm on top of it
but fundamentally at the end of the day
he believes that he is the superior to
what he sees as a physically inferior
other male
and that that he has an inherent
right to the body of a woman
i i don't know what to call that other
than toxic masculinity
uh
as kids were super grover but as adults
were the monster at the end of this book
uh grover's the best i love grover so
much
glenn is going to be in the film version
of lloyd webber's sunset boulevard so
i'm pretty sure she will win for that
lloyd webber did sunset boulevar wait
what
all right i'm out of the loop now
good point didn't think of it that way
i'm here to help
ah
that that is the octopus costume from
freaking
love actually that was it haha
so liz texted me uh jean
uh young i'm gonna mispronounce this
yon young zhong is not going to socially
distance from brad pitt she totally took
his arm
[Laughter]
uh
this looks like a job for supergirl grov
grovel
grover see for me the epitome of super
grover is actually
other characters seeing him coming and
it was it's a bird it's a plane it's
ah he would crash super grover and
people were never actually happy to see
him
[Music]
as a kid we were almo but we grew up to
be oscar see i was too
old for elmo was after my time like i
know who elmo
is obviously but elmo was well after my
time
watching sesame street cause i'm old
and my memory is not what it once was
and things like sesame street
fades into the background
something i don't know
uh she's korean she probably got the job
six months ago brad pitt was only in
danger from
her admiration
do you watch saturday night live nope
i do not you're not old i don't think
i'm old in the abstract but like i have
analytics to
show that i am older than the majority
of my audience
there was a time before elmo
go in the corner and think about what
you just said
oh of the two-headed monster oh
yeah he was great
grover's older than i am i can tell you
that i'm pretty sure
uh thoughts on plain knight from outer
space never saw it
but your heart and soul are young i'm
not sure that's
true like i hold on to youthful things
i'm not sure that actually makes me um
young at heart because
i am a jaded cynical
bastard and it's okay for me to say
bastard because i actually am one
some people get offended by that term
which throws me off but
whatever i'm allowed to call myself that
you're not allowed to call me that
that's how that works
have you ever seen the sesame street
movie followed that bird oh yeah oh yeah
that's that's one of my uh
my kid's mother's favorite favorite
movies
were you watching when mr hooper died no
well
yes and no i
how do i put this so
i didn't have tv
in the home growing up my experience was
tv was when i was at my grandparents oh
production design okay and um
like visiting friends and my grandmother
would tape some stuff for me off the tv
and send me tapes of stuff
so i was watching sesame street
at the time that happened
but like not actively as it was airing
so
i i've never seen that episode
i miss carol spinney yeah that that one
hurt
if you if you haven't seen the i am big
bird documentary i
highly recommend you do
who do you think is more inspirational
mr rogers jim henson or stan lee it's
really hard to
top mr rogers they're all wonderfully
inspirational but i
i it is really really hard
to come in above mr rogers
all right how much tape do you have
holding that dress up
i know i would need a lot
what boo
all you did was recreate hearst castle
which is still standing and you go to
reference boo
lazy win boo
i do not support this win
ah
[Music]
um
oh whatever
still heartbroken about jim henson yeah
yeah when that one happened that like i
didn't even
know what to think when that happened
i just i i honestly couldn't wrap my
head around it
i remember hearing that a blind girl
would never know
when he was feeding the fish because she
couldn't see him do it and so he made a
note to always let the audience know
when he fed him yes with mr rogers yes i
heard that too
no one supports any win at the oscars
is muppet to mean a foolish person only
used in the uk
it's not used that way in the us
definitely not
cinematography
i am big burr was tied with inside out
as my favorite film of that year good
good picks both
uh i guess the cinematography in mank
was
fine i didn't think there's anything
impressive about it
i mean if max gonna win anything i
suppose i'll be
more okay with it winning the um
technical award technical kind of awards
because
like if that script had won holy crap
mr rogers made an appearance on sesame
street yeah
yeah i did know that carol spinney was
at a local con a year or two before he
passed
but i'd used up all my spoons the day
before and missed his panel
one of my great regrets oh that's a
shame caroline
i mean like it it happens if you've got
no more spoons you've got no more spoons
my jaw dropped to the part where they
talked about big bird nearly going to
space yeah right
should the oscar should the oscars allow
streaming services to be nominated well
i mean
so the way the rules currently work
a film from a streaming platform
can be nominated but it still has to
have a theatrical run
um concurrent with the release that's
how netflix movies have gotten
nominations they i mean like
and and honestly that is not very far
off
from the way that um a lot of
oscar nominated movies traditionally
would have
a limited release in new york and la
like in the last week of the calendar
year in order to qualify
for the for the oscars for that year and
then
only roll out into a wide release in
like february or
march so i i don't
think that the streaming platforms
releasing a film to a limited run at the
same time that they put it on their
streaming so that it qualifies i
don't think that is very far off oh we
get a sneak peek at um
in the heights
uh lin-manuel
miranda does not look good with a full
beard
hmm
is this mostly a love story
yeah i don't know in the heights as a as
a show
yep i'm definitely tired oh do i like
elmo not
especially not really
are they performing the songs this year
actually rowan they did the songs
during the red carpet um
so no they they're not performing them
doing during the show proper i might
actually have to bail
before this finishes like i it's i'm
just kind of i don't know what it was
something about getting up
to use the bathroom and then come back
i'm just like
my body is going yep okay i'm done
yes ms wikiwolf i know about spice world
i was alive in the 90s i am aware
and the heights is not a love story oh
good
then maybe i'll watch it
i feel the need to specify like i don't
have an inherent problem with love
stories
but they are so rarely done well that
they're
they're never a uh selling point to me
are burton ernie a gay couple
canon no are they
viable to be read as such yes and that's
fair enough to me um
oh erica thank you you get a heart
finally caught a live stream just saying
hello to tell you that i appreciate your
content oh thank you so much
i appreciate that
[Music]
how many
how many more awards are there
uh
could you say they were coded not
intentionally
uh
i i don't think either of them are
actually really particularly gay coded
i just think that their interaction
reads viably as a relationship
six proper ones to go oh god six really
officially scheduled for another 45
minutes okay i think i can do that
i think you can do oh
maybe we'll see
like i might bail i don't know
have you seen spice world no
all right how checked out is harrison 4
gonna seem
i knew i knew it was blade runner i
knew it was going to be blade runner
hahahahaha
i don't know
i don't know what inspired him to read
bad review notes for blade runner but i
kind of love that he did
do you stream from the break room you
mean the channel no i don't stream on
the break room
i stream here and i stream on twitch
not simultaneously but like those are
those are where a stream
editing i don't think i'm gonna
recognize any of these
oh she did her own editing okay that's
cool
yeah charles chicago 7 is not going to
win anything
sorry rowan i'm going to be a jerk in
reader typo as you wrote it
contrary to popular belief bert and
ernie we're not reading
we're not named after the it's a
wonderful life characters i do not know
it's a wonderful life
well enough to remember that there were
characters named bert and ernie in that
hydrate like plain water i've got i've
got i got it
i've got it
okay so i'll ask here how come liz
doesn't join you more often you two look
adorable on the break room couch
together um
mostly logistics it's been a while since
we've
got you need to understand there has to
be a confluence of things
we need to see something together
that she feels like talking about in a
video
video review and then she has to be here
and in the mood to do it um
more often than not when i'm with her i
go and see her at her place
so um
[Music]
when she would appear more often that
was
facilitated by us going to the movies
together like we would go together to a
movie
come back to my place after that and
then
we'd already be here and we'd film a
review of that movie either right after
or the next day
but without that
mechanism it's not as easy for us to do
um video stuff together we've still got
the podcast we still got tough like a
girl
so you can give that a listen um
do you like mineral water not especially
there might be an upset and chicago 7
could get best picture i would be very
surprised
i mean i know how it would happen
because like i mentioned the the way the
voting system works
middling stuff actually uh has a better
shot than it
should but um i would still be kind of
surprised
off topic i loved your video from
earlier today bravo
uh uh that i think that actually you're
probably referring to the one that went
up yesterday but thank you
thank you
the intro to you and liz's bisexual
representation video is my favorite
thing
i don't remember the intro to that one i
remember the intro to the
um infinity war one where she had her
hand all decked out and she did the snap
uh i remember that one
when our cinemas open to uh due to
opening your area well technically they
have but
i'm not vaccinated i'm not setting foot
in the cinema
until i am so technically they are open
technically they've been
open but you know
jesse said you and i are both playful
jerks
i'll just have to decide what i think
about that
do you believe that it's all bought and
paid for no
no i i think i i mentioned this earlier
um
[Music]
the the thing is that um
the nomination process is much closer to
being rigged
than the um
actual award voting process
um it's it's the nominations that i i
honestly tend to find much more
questionable
if you know how the voting
for the actual awards work it makes
sense
now it still results not infrequently
with
winners that maybe shouldn't be the
winners but it's it's actually the
nomination process that i think is more
screwed up
and rigged than the um
than the than the actual award voting
getting vaccinated on the 24th i get my
first shot on the first
i don't know when i'll get the next one
after that because they won't schedule
me for a second until i've had the first
jesse is incapable of being unkind yeah
you know i think you might actually be
right
about that
so this is tyler perry for the
humanitarian award got it
excuse me
you're also capable of being unkind if
you think i am incapable of being unkind
you do not know me very well
i try very hard to not hold many grudges
but i hold on to the ones i have
and i have no plans to let them go
i do not consider myself cruel i make an
effort to not be cruel
but i am not and will not always
be kind
if i'm going to be unkind it will be
with cause
but it does happen and it will happen
so
be careful about
painting me as a saint because i'm not
can i actually relate to what you just
said well thank you that's
good to know
oh
several people related to that
[Laughter]
uh
i i try to the best of my ability
to not ever be cruel
but i cannot always be kind
or cowardly yes never be cruel never be
cowardly
and never ever eat pears
i hate the saying live life with no
regrets because there are some things
that you do regret
the
the no regrets thing is one of those
things that like it's a sentiment
that has value
[Music]
up to a point but
it's it's one of those things that is it
i mean when it gets to the degree of
for a lack of a better comparison like
yolo and the sort of
idiocy where you say well i i'll
i'll live my life with no regrets and
therefore i'll do something really
stupid no
like as a self mantra to
do your best not to let um
fears keep you from experiencing your
life no i get that
but like like most platitudes
it when applied too broadly
it it uh becomes an issue
capaldi's following the live-action
remake i will not consider anyone else
not valid that works
in my day we say carpe diem it's the
same sentiment ultimately and
again like i said it's those kinds of
mantras
are not unhelpful but when they're
treated as absolute truth
then they can be
misdirected
i feel
i'm sorry i'm sorry tyler i i have not
been paying attention
uh
i think he just misstepped there
so
[Music]
for anyone not watching so tyler perry's
giving his
speech accepting the humanitarian award
and he he went off on a thing about
refusing
hate and he says you know i i
will not ever hate um you know people
for this
or that and i don't ever want to see
people hate for this or that
and it started out fine you know he said
for being
um for being latino or black
or white or lgbtq
and then he said oh i or a cop
and i think the problem there
was it felt like he was hedging his bets
by saying that because it was the only
thing that he said
that was not an immutable fact of what
someone is
being a cop's a job you can stop
being a cop and while i'm not saying
that he's wrong in his sentiment that
it's probably unhelpful
to automatically hate cops or to hate
someone for just being a cop
i think listing cop in a list of
immutable unchangeable things about
oneself
like your race your ethnicity
your sexual or gender orientation
is misguided
is he seriously trying to verify people
this i don't think he is
a black cover i think
i think there was some part of him
that was worried about being too
confrontational and the way he chose to
try and hedge his bets was
ill-advised
how would you feel if later it was
revealed
that the doctor would die if he ate
pears bringing it full circle
like the celery thing
that would be amusing
hmm
sorry texting liz
do you like oreos yes yes i do double
stuff's the best
fun fact ratigan was originally a lot
thinner but they changed his design when
vincent
was cast really i can't i can't picture
rattigan not being you know the big
hulking figure
and it's actually kind of more
interesting to me because like vincent
price's voice doesn't
naturally lend itself to a big
intimidating figure
so that's actually rather interesting
i like mentors the mints are okay
forgiveness of oneself can be
exceedingly difficult i don't know if
i'll ever succeed
um
i don't know if i have any business
telling anybody how to get better at
forgiving yourself because there are
things that i don't know if i'll
ever fully forgive myself for but i have
gotten to the point where i am not
beating myself up over them anymore
either i still
carry a lot of weight about them
but i don't
continually um
[Music]
tear myself down because of them and i
consider that a decent amount of
progress
trent resident for seoul that is so
weird to me that trent resner did the
soundtrack to seoul
excuse me
half an hour i can make it i think maybe
i don't know
uh
sorry checking spam mail
because i don't think i really care
about whatever speech
trent resner is going to give um have
you seen theater of blood i have not
dang it oh man i don't know if i'll make
it
ugh
i like christmas orders because the red
filling is pretty it is
uh i don't think i can make it and i
wasn't even tired
yeah we'll see
oh i'm not spreading the yawns too much
through the uh
through the livestream oh boy
i'll tell you as soon as this is over
i'm crashing
so hard have you had a jammy dodger
yes uh i had some sent to me
a while back um by a subscriber
but i had some people advise me that
what was sent were not the good
kind so i i i honestly don't know
um
i i i am digging this guy's speech he is
very happy to be there
do you like chips ahoy not really have
you had jelly babies yes
they're weird they've got that coating
on them i don't know what that is that's
weird
i like that even though trent reznor is
like the biggest
name of these people that he's he did
not step up to the mic
first
ah
good god
do you like cereal some of it i like
granola style cereal
mostly i don't go in for the super
sugary stuff
that's all over the place in the u.s
because like it it's
cloying and then i can't shake that
flavor for a while
oh they i they let him have the whole
speech time
oh dig that i like it i
like it
uh oh okay we're
uh we gotta do original song now
i can still can't believe nine ish nails
is part of the disney universe it
it is odd to think about isn't it do you
have scoops ahoy nope
not anywhere near me at any rate
one night in miami
seems like a decent song
hmm
huh i don't know what the life ahead is
this is a decent tune though
what is your favorite flavor of ice
cream it is entirely mood dependent
and
this song is okay
i did actually catch the performance of
this one that was good
so this eurovision thing is
okay
have you done karaoke before yeah been a
long time
cool i support that win
ah and they're so excited i love it when
they're clearly really excited to
to get the award
zendaya is rocking the midriff show that
was a good look
who won uh judas and the black messiah
one
oh dang she's so sparkly
oh
i think all the ice cream i've got left
right now is blood orange sorbet
oh i have not had blood orange sorbet in
forever
oh that stuff's really good
i am all of a sudden jealous now
i mean for for ice cream broadly
speaking i am partial to ben and jerry's
cuz
i'm a vermonter so things like triple
caramel chunk
coffee coffee buzz buzz buzz i really
love vermonty python but they
discontinued that one
uh oh and mint chocolate cookie oh
that one's good i haven't had that in
ages
is porn cheating um
not inherently it
if
if you are lying to your partner
about partaking in porn especially if
they have expressed to you a discomfort
with that and you do it anyway and keep
it from them
cheating might be an overstatement but
it is definitely a betrayal of
trust which is
a similar root issue as
cheating so that's
that's about as far as i'll go with that
i don't know how that question came up
steven spielberg is directing a new film
adaptation of west side story yep uh
yeah the the teaser was actually part of
this
airing um kj
zanna um so yeah i saw it it looked
like west side story
so we just have the memorium and the
final three left okay
oh okay i can do this i can do this i
can do this
have you ever done a fan dub before no
don't i don't think they're that funny
what is going on i
i don't understand what's going on
are are they doing karaoke what the what
the hell is this
uh
i'm not watching it but participating in
it participating in it
no it's
it's never cheating unless the other
person
has said they do not wish you to do that
so
if you are participating if you are a
pornographic performer and you are with
a partner
who knows what you're doing and supports
what you're doing it's not
cheating cheating at its heart what is
what does it mean to cheat
when you cheat you break the rules so if
there's no
rule in your relationship forbidding an
activity
then engaging in that activity is not
cheating now
the way i worded that that doesn't mean
well we never talked about us
doing this so you didn't say i couldn't
that's not what i'm talking about forget
that
but i'm saying like if if the rules of
your relationship
make an action permissible even if it
would
be considered cheating in most other
relationships because most others would
not permit it
it's not cheating in your relationship
because your relationship permits it
you're not breaking your
rules and if you're not breaking the
rules then you're not
cheating not participating well when i
did my first answer
that was watching so i answered that
already
so i'm not sure why you why you asked
for
clarification when i that's how i
answered it the first time
i'm very confused now
what a what are they doing what is this
this super awkward karaoke thing what is
this
another song that perfectly defines you
is bringing sexy back by just
so here's the funny thing about bringing
sexy back
when i was why do you just stop
whatever you're doing just stop
anyways anyways dear god
um so here's the thing about
bringing sexy back
um when i was in new york
and i was in a drag troupe
called switch and play
and one of the um group numbers we had
was a um
justin timberlake medley
and the point at which i came in on that
song
was sexy back that was about two-thirds
of the way into the song
was where i came in strutting in
to i'm bringing sexy back
and uh and basically having the other
performers clamoring over me for the
remainder of that number
uh i have not been in a group
burlesque performance number in a long
time kinda miss it
do you think it would ever be possible
to get rowan atkinson as the actual
doctor said of just the red nose special
i'm not sure anyone would be able to
take it seriously
that's to say he couldn't do it but i i
just don't know
if if they would ever be able to
accept oh what
what is this this okay this is so
this is some golden globes nonsense
the fact that they're not drunk makes
this all the more awkward
good grief
ugh
timberlake is super problematic just
saying yeah i i am aware of that and
like
this number was from like
12 years ago so you know
we'd love to see a video that i don't
think there is video of that number
maybe hang on
that would have to look way back
uh let me see here
if i go way back
nope
i do not think there is video of that
number
hmm
ah this is i'm looking at videos
online seeing what i can find
all right what was what's this one
nope that oh god i'm sorry i'm just
finding old numbers
oh wow that would that's an old one jeez
uh yeah i wouldn't take any of these
things down but
i am looking at these and being a bit
like oh
boy that's rough
okay i'm not finding it so there you go
uh i think sexy back was the first time
the word twerk was used in popular
culture
possibly i don't know i wouldn't i would
be careful about accrediting that
uh i miss right said fred
i'm too sexy for my shirt
uh
oh stretch
[Music]
ah what's your favorite backstreet boy
song
um
good grief um hey there silent chariot
thank you for becoming a member you know
what you
you can get a heart
bye everyone i gotta go to bed yeah
donna as soon as this is that
it's ten minutes left i can make it but
i'm crashing so hard as soon as this is
over
uh
oh yes right said fred the kova deniers
oh are they
oh but i was asked favorite backstreet
boys song um
[Music]
everybody
and no i'm not gonna sing it
uh
[Music]
although oh you know you know what else
was really good
larger than life was good
yeah i like that one
slithering into satin sheets no just so
just go ahead and slither in
what's a scotsman with ruined teeth i
don't know
what is a scotsman with ruined teeth
gonna regret asking that
uh
if you're not going to say you aren't
drunk enough i'm not i'm done i'm not
drinking
more i'm well hydrated i'm good
i'm good
angela bassett nice
don't worry you'll answer it
i'm confused and i don't get it and
don't
don't make me think about things
ah in memoriam okay
oh
well because you know the other
backstreet boy that's that's a good one
you are my fire
that's it that's all you get
oh
her muscle definition
is gorgeously terrifying
if we see emily in paris on netflix no
either chadwick or uh christopher palmer
will be the last name
liz's money is on chadwick boseman
and i'm inclined to agree cecily tyson
ian holm oh man that was in the last
year
max final oh god klaus leachman
wow he offered condo we lost a lot
schumacher oh my god
olivia de havilland
yeah some of the oh there's there's
plumber
oh wilfred wilford brimley that's right
fred willard i forgot about that ah
karl reiner
good grief
oh alan parker i don't think i realize
he died
or if he did i forgot
brian dennehy
diana rigg
that one hurt
they are burning through these at quite
a pace
jerry stiller dmx
i think liz was right i think they're
gonna end on chadwick boseman
sean connery yep forgot about that
there it is there it is she called it
she called it
i wonder if that was the name so i know
what the name of the song is
uh
i hadn't known about jerry stiller i
think most of these i
heard about at some point but some i'd
forgotten
were i'd either forgotten at all i've
forgotten we're so recent
all right they're running overtime
sons of ugh
i think we all knew what clip they chose
for terry jones at last year's one
i didn't watch last year's oscars i
think i just checked out the results
after the fact
did you know the little mermaids on
broadway i knew that yeah
i forgot to schedule overtime
uh i mean the it always runs over time
it's just a question of by how much oh
um
oh come on uh
one thing i definitely don't care about
is the advertisements
uh why do they let it run over time
because
it always runs over time it is never not
run over time
um you know maybe if they'd cut that
really weird awkward karaoke segment
we'd be on time right now
you don't seem to be having fun you
should get some rest there's only three
awards left
i can do this i've come this far
come on
oh rita moreno cool
oh she's so humble i love it
they're doing best picture before the
actors
that what
huh
my clock says 11 we all know it's
midnight feels like it
what do you think of the big bang theory
do you think it's a fun
watch or misrepresentation of geeks as a
whole i think the big bang theory
is and i'm gonna grant myself my one
curse for the stream
is a [ __ ] travesty of a show
who doesn't love rita moreno nobody i
know
somebody doesn't love rita moreno i
don't i don't need to know them
why is the clip from mank
him being stripped what
oh
i know mad land's gonna take this
oh ramya i'm glad we're uh we're on the
same page
there speaking up muppets from earlier
rita moreno an animal was classic i've
seen that clip that's good stuff
he's being stripped of an oscar i hope
so uh
uh okay come on come on come on come on
come on
i don't know if i knew bo burnham was in
that movie
huh
okay
sorry i've gotten so quiet you can tell
i'm a bit tired
oh
i see uh big bang theory seems to be the
topic of the chat now
so
called it that's what i thought it was
gonna be oh i didn't say it out loud
though i texted liz that i figured no
mad limb was gonna take it i don't know
if i actually said it
to you folks but i did call it
uh
okay very cool
i never had an interest in the big bang
theory
because it was treading
in the exact same
nerd and geek oh look they're so smart
but they don't know how to talk to
people
oh look they like star wars and are
super awkward
stereotypes that have been the mainstay
of
depictions of geeks since goddamn
revenge of the
nerds
you don't get credit for putting
geeky characters as your main leads
if you're dealing in the same tired
look at the nerds aren't they so awkward
nonsense
that has been around for over 30 years
so the idea i used to find it honestly
very offensive that people thought i
would like that because i am also a geek
it's because i am also a geek that i
found it
offensive feels like a slight
overstatement because like a geek is
about being an interest and i feel like
truly offended should be a bit more
reserved for
something more deeply hurtful but i did
feel insulted
by that show
okay two more two more two more
as one of the producers francis has her
third oscar well she might get her
fourth
uh in a little bit too
communities better i started community i
didn't get very far not that it was bad
but i just decided i'd rather do
something else
um
oh oh
my legs are not loving me for sitting in
this chair for as long as i
have oh
okay okay so it's
it's two awards left we can do this
as soon as they say who it is though i'm
done i'm not
not sticking around for the speech
oh just go to bed no
i will not concede defeat
i am a stubborn [ __ ]
uh i've heard of zoey's extraordinary
playlist but i absolutely
have no idea what it's actually about so
should have streamed from your path for
the oscars
[Laughter]
uh that's a thought
oh
you're not a [ __ ] well i'm still
staying up to watch this instead of
going
to bed so
let me self-deprecate all right don't
what is with this song choice
don't you forget about me
ah
ah as you walk on bye
go to bed and have an awkward dream
about oscar's karaoke that never ends
ah no
huh
god damn it
i knew it i i um
wow that like
this was the one person who i didn't
want to win and let me be very clear
there's nothing wrong with francis
mcdormand
i have nothing against her she is an
excellent actress i'm sure she's
excellent in the role
but from what i've seen from clips and
trailers
it's the same damn
performance she got an oscar for when
she was in
three billboards give it
to somebody else
god damn it at least she was brief
what was your reaction when they
announced that the big bang theory was
ending
i can recreate my reaction for you
oh is that [ __ ] still on hmm
i thought for sure this was viola like
any one of the others
would have been better
i'm just very frustrated by that one
i don't have a problem with actors
winning more than once
i do kind of take issue when they win
more than once for a very
similar role which is what just happened
with her
are actors who basically play themselves
lesser actors even if they're really
enjoyable to watch
not necessarily
but um
i i do hesitate heaping too much praise
if they effectively play the same role
every time
that doesn't make them a bad actor it
does make them a limited
actor chadwick will get this
gilman does not need another oscar
oh god
oh [ __ ]
okay i didn't call that at all
huh
anthony hopkins just won for best actor
i was dead certain they were going to
give it to chadwick boseman
i don't i i know almost nothing about
the father i don't
i don't i i don't know how he was i'm
sure he was fine he's always good
huh i'm not even necessarily sure like
in a vacuum
i'm not sure that chadwick boseman's
performance
was
award-worthy but
i i really did think this was going to
be a case where
the academy knew that they would not
ever be able to award him again because
he passed away
so i thought that has hopkins won before
yeah he has he won for
science of the lambs back in 91.
um
yeah that's
huh i was not expecting that
i think he was one of the only ones that
i kind of took it as a given that
he wasn't going to win
ah
weird
no no black cover anthony hopkins didn't
pass away chadwick boseman did
um
[Music]
it's a family drama about a man with
dementia it's apparently his best
rolling years
oh okay i will probably never watch it
um
[Music]
my grandfather had dementia
and
that's not
i've watched some films where
they were about dementia but like kind
of sneakily
so like say um
mr holmes or
robot and frank are ultimately about
dementia but they come at it from
a slightly sideways angle which is what
i need if if
i go into something that's just like
it's about dementia i'm like i can't
i just i i can't
but oh that's it that's
uh that's the oscars i'm gonna go crash
i'm gonna go crash
hard thank you all for joining me
hope you had fun and
uh take care of yourselves
be safe
be well be kind
and remember that you are beautiful
you are valid you are loved
and i am damn tired
but you're the one who's the council i'm
just running the meetings and until next
time
this council
is going to bed
night